[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
sunday there's no show all of us went to
the seattle seahawk game eight of us
no money rolling deep you know one of us
would get a beer and give sips to each
other two of us smoking a joint you know
that's something i'll never forget yeah
yeah you know do you think that'll
happen in l.a in some circles
yeah a little bit it's just it's just a
lot easier when you're young in the game
and you got those eight people what do i
tell you every monday did you call eric
did you call the agostino did you call
[ __ ]
those are you but those are them i got
nothing for you i can't take you to the
store with me right but the agostino got
a room in el centro they gave you three
tacos and 25 bucks what are you looking
at me for yeah that's that's the you got
a call every monday the agostino [ __ ]
uh
rodrigo
the other kid johnny rock every monday
those are your friends those are who you
live and die with there's no money
there's no nothing
it's six guys or the comedy buddies so
if one of them gets a gig you all eat
yeah
one of them gets a gig he's gonna go in
there and go hey do you know who [ __ ]
santino is no i don't he was and i'm
dying up here get him in here right
that's what that bond is for right not
to hang out with 18 [ __ ] losers
you have to build that six or seven guys
and you live and die with them he's a
girl the girl's hot she's a [ __ ] you
don't [ __ ] her yeah because she's gonna
[ __ ] the manager for you to come back
right
you feed her to the manager come here
yeah how was your family and friends
towards the arts were they open-minded
well you know
right that's all all right you just
[ __ ] said it
you just said it you know like every
time i go home it's like how's how's
hollywood big shot you know with all
those homos in hollywood you know you're
like you're such a you're a queer
because you came out here that's what it
is you suck a deck out there in
hollywood you suck at deck by the beach
you'd rollerblades it immediately it's
all this like they [ __ ] on the idea of
this thing and
look people say that all the time comedy
in chicago is incredible it's it's an
amazing scene you could stay there could
have stayed you could stay yeah never
leave no make a living but i thought i
don't want to be
home i want to take a shot i wanted to
take a shot like lee decided to bring
his mom to open mice and she gave him a
piece of her mind this week which really
thought
because you don't see it no
you don't see it you're you're in love
she's sucking 20 dicks on the back door
but she comes out front and tells you
she was a nun right last week and you
believe it you don't see that she's got
sperm coming out
and you know somebody came in their
eyebrow you don't see it because we're
so in love with what we're doing yeah
that's the [ __ ] reality check when
people like i don't know how you do this
you gotta sit there every night with
these mental health [ __ ] patient
because that's all an open mic is 50
percent of people just got out they got
long sweaters to hide the bracelets
right the cuts yeah hide all the cuts in
life whether you're a dentist that you
always have that
those moments which
you go wow why would i keep doing this
yeah
why the [ __ ] would i keep doing this
yeah this guy keeps throwing bricks from
the third floor on my [ __ ] head yeah
i gotta walk around with a hard hat it's
dirty below
you know the carpenters are off but i
still gotta load the job right you know
i gotta load the brick and load the
[ __ ] 90 pound rolls of tarp paper up
on the roof
and you know there's so many [ __ ]
struggles in life that you go through
yeah the best when somebody looks you in
the eye when you're young and goes
yeah in six years
six years it's like when you go to the
army recruiter when you're 18 you just
got your dick sucked the night before by
some skinny chick that was babysitting
two doors down
and you're like so what do i what are we
doing here okay we take a test and if
you [ __ ]
pass they send you the camp pendleton
you do jumping jacks for eight weeks
and then you they send you off and then
you do 20 years yeah when you're 18 and
somebody says 20 years to you
in like 20 years yeah go [ __ ] you take
this feather and shove it up your
eyeball or whatever the [ __ ] rogan's a
straight decent guy very generous
i'm a criminal
we have nothing in common right we only
have one thing in common joe and i that
we
how holy we hold the religion of comedy
yeah
how sacred we hold the religion of
comedy
i don't give a [ __ ] about anything my
friend
i really don't i give a [ __ ] about that
little girl
i give a [ __ ] about my wife but if she
wants to go she got to go
you know
you know there's so many things in this
life that are replaceable
comedy is never going to be replaceable
in my life or your life no it's never
going to be replaceable i never wanted
to be replaced i could care less yeah
all the other [ __ ] sucks a baseball game
or a basket when you fall in love with
comedy nothing else matters yeah there's
only one thing that matters the [ __ ]
you're going to get afterward
and the joint you're going to smoke wolf
was here last week talking about he did
warm up if he pre-fontaine they're
painting 800 a day he brought me down
the second week gave me 100 a day and i
was there just stealing [ __ ]
t-shirts
we were gonna plan to rob the joint like
they raffled the car it was a lot of
extras so for you to stay all day they
would make you raffle a car i go let me
give you the winning number
we'll raffle the car i win and then
we'll sell the car and split it growing
old sucks
yeah really sure you're back
you go to bed earlier you know your dick
don't get harder than you use
yours does mine does yeah
yeah
but
i will tell you something what the best
thing about getting old is is seeing
people's growth yeah
it keeps you alive here i'm gonna blow
your mind first time i went out on the
road with joe
he was a 3 000 a week comic
and he couldn't sell out seven shows at
the improv in miami right
sold out the weekend right but thursday
was men's and men's wednesday was men's
amends
so
that's been a growth of
21 years yeah
if you're not into this for 21 years
it's not gonna work if
if you're not all in with both your guns
feet
well i don't care what you don't like
sorry doesn't really matter i'm sure
along the way joe didn't like a thousand
things either right but i want you to
fathom that around your head
he was a
when he was on news ask him
when he was on news radio
one of the first gigs he did was
caroline's and he lost money on the game
because the plane ticket was more than
what he got right right
plane ticket was more than they paid him
now this is at the
98th he had been doing comedy maybe 12
years yeah so if you're willing to take
a loss in comedy your 12th year
what are you talking about yeah you must
really [ __ ] care what are you talking
about yeah it's wild so that's what you
know watching him doing what he's doing
him watching us
you know me and ari were his
backhandlers yeah and dust and john you
know it was me ari hammond redman
red band was the camera attack
duncan me and ari
three guys in front of him doing ten
apiece that's why that's called [ __ ]
and people used to tell them you
shouldn't bring diaz and ari that loses
and he said go wait wait just [ __ ]
wait just [ __ ] wait i see it you guys
don't see it because oh you're looking
at the ticket sales right but i see it
from the comedy they're killing at the
comedy store shut the [ __ ] up
and that was it the education of joe
rogan
you know i was telling somebody here the
first time he called me and said let's
go work out
i'm like are you [ __ ]
on vacation yeah who works on vacation
yeah work out go [ __ ] yourself
work out
you'd see him when i was an hour later
all sweaty telling you how good he feels
yeah i feel better i've been over here
watching lawn artists smoking wreath
sausage stuff from the pizza place and
you're the other sweating like a pig
guess what i [ __ ] work out on the
road now yeah i'm saying that yeah you
got to get on stage your legs got to be
strong there's a lot of work and when
you're done it feels really good to get
back into the swing of comedy i never
stopped doing comedy when i was shooting
that show i'd if i could get off early
enough i would go do spots
and sometimes adam would pull me aside
and be like you're tired bro
take a couple nights yeah you i don't
like that yeah when you're here for a
long time you realize you know it's the
worst thing in the world is having a 10
30 mm-hmm and it's six o'clock and
you're still on the set yeah it's hard
and there's a scene left yep and they
still gotta turn around right and you're
like and now your leg is tapping and now
you're looking at your clock
and it's a great feeling as a comic to
go i shot today and i stopped by the
store and did this yeah there's no
better feeling yeah that's like getting
a [ __ ] and getting you getting your
ass eaten out with a [ __ ] one of
those straws with a long tongue
you can't beat him like did you see the
preacher in knoxville did you see about
this preacher in knoxville what a plan
nah nah nah that's funny as [ __ ] that
was a funny interview no no this
preacher in knoxville is going on the
other day leviticus oh yeah 22 about
like killing gays like he's like we got
dude this guy was like a sh uh he's the
chief of the police
and he's on there being like killed the
bible says these sodomites need to be
murdered i mean he's talking he's like
preaching murder and this guy's the head
of the cops bro in knoxville is that
where it was somewhere like that yeah
kept preaching murder to his church and
he's like you don't like it get out i
was like this [ __ ] is serious
about this hate i mean that's not like
say some foul [ __ ] at the house to
somebody like you know i'm not really a
fan of [ __ ] puerto ricans no this is
guy he's on the stand screaming at a
church
full of people being like these homos
need to get taken down where they live
go go to the parade take them all out at
the parade this motherfucker's crazy
there's some place in this country it's
still 1970. i know dude this
[ __ ] was not some people like
that oh well listen there was enough
people there that were loving it some
people liked it they were cheering it
out i wanted it but here's the big thing
you know who would have got that job if
he didn't kill himself freddie prince
freddie prince yeah freddie prince is
going to be the host of the whole light
show that [ __ ] even looked good
he was phenomenal he was phenomenal yeah
and the funny thing is if you listen to
eddie uh
what's his first name
freddie prince yeah freddie if you
listen to freddie live from chicago
there's a cd me and rogan bought it one
time we had to throw it out the window
it's terrible stand up in the 70s oh
yeah was really you could see where and
it's not that it progressed but i don't
know if it was the subject matter
because
brian had some brilliant albums in the
[ __ ] 70s that was his
you know those bicentennial [ __ ] and
their brother before that those were
just masterpieces but you know we know
why i think that was because they were
about him
prior did a lot of stuff about prior a
lot of other guys did a lot of stuff
about what's happening what's happening
in the world right and what's happening
in the world doesn't
nothing is evergreen right like nothing
in comedy
uh politically is evergreen jokes that
were funny 20 years ago about what's
happening probably not that [ __ ]
funny anymore because it's not happening
we've moved so much forward you know
what i mean so um when your materials
about you like pryor did it so well
it it lives forever because it's so
personal you know think about your mom
smoking crack and sucking [ __ ] in front
of you when you're nine
you know
[Music]
is a dark place
[Music]